l'état quand il veut peut avoir un
déficit public
les banques automatiquement rachète ses
titres parce qu'ils ont la garantie que
la bce va effectivement les refinancer
et la proposition un peu saugrenue que
nous venons d'entendre consiste à dire
cette dette publique de l'état
on va décider à part on va décider que
ça va devenir une dette publique de la
bce
or si on fait ça on peut faire ça d'un
trait de plus ça ne modifie en rien aux
rien les revenus ou le patrimoine
d'aucuns agents autre que la bce et
l'état sachant par ailleurs que la bce
est la propriété des états membres de
façon générale est donc cette mesure
n'aurait strictement strictement aucune
conséquence c'est un s'est vraiment
donné un coup de couteau dans l'eau
alors naturellement personne ne sera
dupe
parce que étant donné que la bce
appartient aux états la dette de la bce
naturellement serait automatiquement
harper parti entre les états donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle de la comptabilité
créative ce que ce café neurones où
n'importe quand n'importe quelle
entreprise qui fraudent ça consiste à
masquer sa dette en disant je vais le
l'attribué à une filiale à une
succursale
oui
[Musique]